Ich bin wieder am Start, gucken ob das jetzt wieder funktioniert, F5, so.
Gucken wir mal ob alles wieder klappt, was ist das für eine Kacke, das habe ich jetzt erst seit dem letzten Windows Update, dass das asynchron wird, komisch, ganz ganz komisch, so, jetzt gucken wir mal ob wieder alles passt,
Training, Practice Range, jetzt passts wieder, oder, jetzt sollte es wieder passen,
das muss ich mir echt mal angucken, was der für Schmerzen hat, warum das so rumwagt, aber vor allem das lustige ist, erst seit einer Weile, passt wieder alles, sagt man Blitz,
sollte alles passen, ne,
ok, dann gehts jetzt weiter, Game war etwas leise, vielleicht hat es sich wieder umgestellt, ne, passt eigentlich, ah ne, jetzt, ok, passt, jetzt sollte in-game-sound passen,
jetzt sollte in-game-sound gleich wieder passen, gut, weiter gehts, paar Runden machen wir noch, paar Runden machen wir noch, was hat, oh, Instant Match,
Instant Match, was spielen wir denn jetzt, ich warte mal was die anderen picken, was ist das für eine DPS Combo, komm wir spielen mal Anna, haben wir eine Weile nicht gespielt,
hast du Tipps fürs Bewerbungsgespräch als studentische Hilfskraft in der Softwareentwicklung, ja, hast du Vorkenntnisse, kannst du irgendwas besonders gut, dann ist das natürlich nicht verkehrt,
sich das da noch mal beim passenden Moment hervorzuheben, dass man in dem und dem Bereich auch schon Erfahrungen gesammelt hat, und warum das besonders gut zu dieser Firma passt,
das ist generell auch nicht verkehrt, wenn du ungefähr eine Ahnung hast, bei welchem Laden du dich bewirbst, ich finde man muss das da nicht übertreiben, ja, also was ich immer ein bisschen beschreut finde,
manche Betriebe erwarten von jetzt, ich red jetzt mal von Azubis, ja, generell wenn man sich irgendwo bewirbt, erwarten manche Betriebe den mega Einsatz von den Leuten, ja, den übertriebenen Einsatz,
so nach dem Motto, du musst am ehesten noch wissen, wie die Sterne in welche, ob die Sterne in einer Reihe gestanden haben als die Firma gegründet wurde, quasi die wollen alles, die wollen dass du alles wissen,
dich mega beschäftig hast mit der Firma, aber sie selbst gehen null auf die Bewerber ein, ja, so nach dem Motto Bewerbung zurück mit Kaffeeabdrücken drauf und sowas, das ist totales Ungleichgewicht,
deswegen bin ich der Ansicht, man muss es nicht übertreiben, sich ein bisschen mit der Firma beschäftigen ist gut, aber man will da arbeiten, man muss die Firma nicht vergöttern oder so,
was haben wir eigentlich für ein Komp, geht einsch, was sind das schon wieder die Winner, huge, ich kann nicht auf allen Seiten heilen, das funktioniert nicht, das funktioniert echt nicht,
das funktioniert so nicht, Mercy hat Priorität, Winston, Winston, Winston,
ich blick nochmal durch, ich blick nochmal durch, das wird zu hoch,
das ist mir zu hoch gerade, was hier passiert, was ist das hier, können wir uns mal darauf einigen, dass wir in eine Richtung, in eine Richtung bewegen,
nein, das ist einfach, einfach wir, das ist wirklich jeder in eine andere Richtung, was willst du denn da machen,
der Winston stirbt jetzt, ok, der ultet, auch gut, der ultet um zurück zu fallen, wie nanobustig ist hier überhaupt unsere D.Va,
auf D.Va, go, alter, meine Fresse bewegt euch nach vorne, ich flippe aus,
ich weiß, was machen die denn da gerade,
das ist ja echt, ja, Winston, warum wartet er denn nicht, meine Fresse, will er da ohne Support rein,
Winston, Winston, Winston, ich nanobuste jetzt einfach mal random irgendwas, ich blick nicht mehr durch, ganz ehrlich, das ist mir viel zu hoch,
das ist so ein krass, ultra, wirres, mega wirres Match, ich muss da schnell wieder hin, oder auch nicht,
das ist also übrigens ok, dass die so weit vorpushen, selbst wenn sie sterben, da kriegen wir den, kriegen wir den Card weiter gepusht,
da muss er ja unter der Brücke durch, das ist das wichtigste,
das ist schön, die sollen Ultis wasten, die sollen Ultis wasten, das ist das wichtigste, hauptsache die wasten Ultis, Ultis wasten, beste,
easy, easy clap, ich muss Ult kriegen, ich muss Ult kriegen, wichtig,
die müsst ihr selbst killen da drin, und dann Ulten, weil wir hier angreifen, mach den platt,
oh, NA, nicht gut, nicht gut, die hätt ich aufheben müssen,
das ist anstrengend, das ist echt anstrengend,
ich muss mir echt mal angucken, warum dieses Sound, wie lang lief das Stream jetzt ungefähr, bis das Sound out of sync gegangen ist,
also ungefähr 10 Matches, oder, dann sagen wir mal so eineinhalb Stunden, eineinhalb bis zwei Stunden, dann geht das Sound out of sync,
ich weiß echt nicht warum, warum geht das Sound out of sync, spielen wir mal brutzel brutzel, wollen wir mal brutzel spielen,
wir können auch sense spielen, lohnt es sich jetzt noch mit Overwatch anzufangen zu trainieren und dann rank zu spielen auf PS4,
also Konsole weiß ich nicht, keine Ahnung, da weiß ich nicht wie es mit Spielerzahlen aussieht und wie das da so läuft,
echt keine Ahnung, auf dem PC würde ich sagen, wenn ihr das Spiel Spaß macht, ja, aber vielleicht nicht so sehr übertreiben,
sonst hast du bald keinen Spaß mehr dran, wenn du da so richtig voll einsteigst und dich reinsteigerst,
weil Overwatch hat ein ziemlich hohes Tilt und Toxic Potential, da muss man ein bisschen aufpassen,
wenn man das Spiel Spaß macht.
Wollen flamen die sich jetzt hier gerade im Chat, weil wir gewonnen haben oder wie?
Ok, wenn die eine gescheite Widow haben, dann kommt die hier gleich langgejumpt oder so und will mich picken,
deswegen verpisse ich mich mal hier hinten in die Ecke.
Ich bin in der Widow.
Schöner Tracer.
Oh mein Aim.
Hopp, hopp, geht runter, nein.
Alter, Alter, was ist hier los?
Nee, nee, nee, das funktioniert nicht.
Zu wenig Protection da.
Wir sollten nicht staggern, wir sollten lieber den zweiten Punkt ordentlich halten.
Oh, krasses Aim.
Was machen wir denn?
Gehen wir mal hoch.
Oh, was ist das für ein Match wieder?
Ich gehe mal unten lang.
Fuck.
Das hat er gut gemacht.
So musst du es aber machen, du musst die Supporter ficken als Winston.
Da hat er ein bisschen was noch gebraucht.
Das ist das Einzige, was du als Ana eigentlich gescheit machen kannst.
Du musst entweder den Sleep da treffen, das geht, weil man da richtig gut drin ist,
aber du musst ihn mindestens mal lila machen.
Und jetzt nicht staggern, sondern schön zurück.
Das kriegen wir doch nie wieder.
Come back, come back.
Na, bist du?
Ach, Mann.
Okay, das war Overkill.
Das war Overkill.
Kenji willst du sterben?
Hinter mir, hinter mir, über mir, irgendwo, ich hör hier was rumlaufen.
Rekt.
Fick dich, Tracer.
Komm zurück.
Oh, Mann.
Reaper, Reaper.
Ups, Ups, Ups.
Ich wollte den Genji ulten.
Mann, steh mal nicht in der Sonne.
Tracer left.
Oh, ich werd gerätzt, huge.
Oh, Mann, ich treff ja nix.
Ha, ich muss mehr heilen anstatt Damage machen.
Aber in der Zeit müssen sie mich auch ficken, ey.
Star ist eindeutig zu wenig Damage gefahren worden.
Ich hätte das schon besser supporten können, ja.
Und ich hätte vor allem jetzt Deep Darts treffen müssen.
Aber da hätte auch mehr, mehr reinhauen müssen, ja.
Da hätte mehr umfallen müssen.
Was, was, was?
Guckt euch mal wieder an, was ist mit denen schon wieder los hier?
Was ist mit denen schon wieder los?
Ich glaub, ich muss hier irgendwas anderes spielen.
Ich würd gern Zen spielen.
Aber man hat zu wenig Protection einfach nur.
Du droppst bei Teamfight von 200 auf 130 FPS.
Ja, ja, von 200 auf 130 ist ja, geht ja schon, ne.
Wir gucken mal, wir gucken mal, ob das mit Zen funktioniert.
Ich kann eine Ana machen. Wenn er eine Ana will, kriegt er eine Ana.
Ups, es geht ja schon los.
Ich würd gerne Genji heilen, aber ich seh' ihn nicht.
Hinter uns, hinter uns, hinter uns.
Warte, bis meine Granate da ist.
Schlemme, Schlemme, Schlemme, Schlemme.
Hehe, Hectorino.
Ach, geh mir aus der Sonne.
Stellt euch nie vorne Ana.
Sleep Darts.
Da müssen wir jetzt durchpushen, ihr könnt ruhig vor.
Ich seh' nicht alles.
Go, go, oder jetzt, jetzt zu spät.
Die Sleep Darts sind strong diesmal.
Winston soll ich dich nicht heilen?
Overtime Push des Todes, äh.
Don't see nine.
Zu weit, zu weit vorne.
Okay, mehr ging nicht, mehr ging nicht.
Mehr ging nicht.
Ich find's als Ana immer schwierig, du musst so inzwischen...
Moment, ich setz' eine raus.
Ich find's als Ana immer schwierig, ähm, du musst so das, das, das, das...
Das Mittelmaß finden, zwischen Damage machen, Gegnern debuffen, sleepen und eigene Leute heilen.
Das ist das, was auch an Ana Spaß macht und was Ana zu einem der schwierigsten Helden im ganzen Game macht.
Also ich finde, neben Genji Tracer ist Ana mit der schwierigste Held.
Genji Tracer, Ana.
Machst du demnächst mal Steam-Profiles sein?
Ja, ich hab's dir schon ewig versprochen, ich mach's demnächst.
Als erstes muss ich mal gucken, was dieser kacke Sound-Async-Geschichte ist.
Warum das nach zwei Stunden immer auftritt, wenn ich Stream neu starten muss.
Stream neu starten ist kacke, weil viele Leute lassen einfach laufen.
Und dann ist auf einmal das Stream weg und dann kriegen sie es nicht mit und denken, das Stream ist off.
Und ah, das sackt einfach nur.
Ich hab extra heute schon mal eine ältere OBS-Version genommen.
Achtung, wir müssen auch wieder aufpassen, falls die hier krasse Sniper-Action haben.
Was, die sollte ein bisschen moveen.
Warum, warum, die hätten sterben müssen, die hätten alle gefickt sein müssen.
Bastion war gesleept plus Purple, die hätten einfach alle direkt umkippen müssen.
Warum sind die nicht alle umgekippt?
Das war huge play, huge play.
Ok, es war ein bisschen bescheuert, als ich runtergetroppt bin, aber ich dachte mir, wir gehen da jetzt drauf, die werden jetzt platt gemacht.
Au, au, au, wir overextenden wieder das Todes.
Ich brauche Heal.
Ich würde Soldier gerne nanoen.
Fuck.
Leute, taunt sie rein.
Huge ana place.
Sag nochmal huge play, ich raste aus.
Ich mag das, ich stehe da voll drauf.
Ich hab mir das angewöhnt.
Ich gucke ja viele Englischsprachigen, Overwatch-Streams und so.
Eines der Standard-Sprüche ist halt immer, egal was du machst, huge play.
Du machst immer huge play.
Huge ult, huge craft, huge res, alles huge.
Unter huge machen wir nix.
Kleiner obito, nee, ich mache es noch.
Ich weiß gar nicht, mache ich noch ne Runde?
Spiel ich?
Ich hab mir echt Kopf weh.
Und ich muss mal im Internet schauen, ob es irgendwo jemand gibt, der...
Ups, irgendwie, ich hab mal eine Verlängerungskabel runtergeschmissen, sehe ich gerade.
Ich muss mal gucken, ob irgendjemand schon irgendwo geschrieben hat, Sound, Async, OBS, Windows 10, Update oder sowas.
Wow, das gab aber viel.
Hast du gleich ein Refling für mich? Ja.
Geh einfach auf YouTube und oben rechts ist der Amazon Refling, direkt auf dem Channel.
Oben rechts beim verlinken.
So Leute, noch ein Game oder kein Game?
Zeit für eins, hätt ich noch.
Ein noch, jawoll.
So, wer ist denn?
Oh, da Frasier streamt BDO, der wird gleich gehostet nach dem Game.
Falls irgendjemand mitgekriegt hat, oder noch andere Leute kennt, die auch Probleme haben, das sind ungefähr eineinhalb Stunden...
Oh, Anubis!
Zwei Stunden der Stream, Out of Sync geht, Audio und Video, da wär ich sehr verbunden, wenn er mir das mitteilen könnte.
Also wenn da irgendjemand Ahnung von hat, sagt Bescheid.
Hello!
Wer spielt denn hier was, zeig mal her.
Alter, wie viele Genji-Mains haben wir denn hier, bitte schön?
Ich spiele nicht Ana, ich kann nicht Mercy spielen, ich trage Mercy.
Shimada!
Was ist das Smurf?
Ja!
Ähm, Moira, please. Nein, nein, nein, Moira nicht.
Alter, der Genji fuckt mich ab. What the fuck? Der Genji, Alter, was geht mir dem ab?
Oh, Doppelsniper, okay, das wird was, Leute, das wird was. Der Genji da oben drauf, ey, lol.
Go, go, go, go!
Hauptsache mal, Hauptsache mal Raketen gegen die Wand geklatscht. Die Widow hat ihre Ult ge-used.
Where is Genji? Is Genji behind?
Fuck.
Ah, fuck down.
Echt, voll in die Fresse.
Oh, ich hab aber Kopfweh, ey, eine Güte. Vier Stunden Streben.
Ah, fuck.
Wer hat sich überlegt, dass das ein guter Held ist?
Warum wasten wir jetzt da alle Ult? Also, ich mein, vielleicht kriegen wir es ja, aber ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass wir es mit 4 gegen 6 quasi jetzt noch holen.
Huge kills.
Wie viele leben noch, wie viele leben noch?
Ist Rank besser geworden oder einfach mal wieder Bock gehabt, einfach mal wieder Bock gehabt?
Das ist übrigens 2 CP, hab ich dir schon mal gesagt.
Fuck, fuck, fuck, ich wollt grad weg.
Warum feeden wir jetzt?
Oh, Mann.
Okay, let's go.
Okay, got the mercy.
Nice.
Ranked hat immer noch seine Probleme. Ich hatte einfach mal wieder Bock. Ranked hat immer noch große Probleme und 2 CP ist auch nicht besser geworden.
Oh, ich hab Kopfweh.
War noch synchron, war so gefragt.
Hast du es Escape from Tarkov gespielt? Nein.
Ist das nicht so ein Survival Game? Oder ist das jetzt ein Survival Game, was sie auch zu Battle Royale umgebaut haben, weil jeder jetzt ihre Games zu Battle Royale umbaut, weil Battle Royale angesagt ist?
Was ist mit dem Typ eigentlich los da?
Jetzt machen sie hier Schwanzvergleich mit Damage Meter. Der eine ist 12, der andere ist 13 oder so, so wie sie sich anhören.
Ja, Pavillion Man, da bin ich mal gespannt drauf.
Positional Q muss sein.
Fuck, die haben uns schon outplayed.
Ich bin schlecht, übelst kacke Positioning.
Null durchgeblickt, was hier abgeht gerade.
Alles total verteilt, links, rechts, sonst wie.
Genji top.
Wo ist der, wo ist der, wo ist der Junkrat?
Der hat Shatter, 100% Shatter.
Na fuck, riesen Headshot Box. Warum, warum challenge ich mit Orisa auch eine Widow, die da am Arsch der Welt steht? Das ist total bescheuert, als könnte ich dagegen irgendwas machen.
Richtig dumm, und jetzt hätte ich Bongos gehabt und Bongo Bongo hätten wir Defenden können.
Bongo Bongo Bongo Bongo Bongo.
Huge.
Da musst du rauf, da musst du, nein Mercy, Mercy.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Mehr konnte ich nicht machen, mehr konnte ich gerade echt nicht machen.
Nee, wir können, das geht, winnable, winnable.
Come back, don't get picked. Hallo, da ist keiner mehr.
Das Schild steht ja mal 1A.
Wo ist die Widow?
Bongo Bongo.
Wallhack.
Barrier steht kacke.
Come on, just leave it.
Ich muss noch mehr Schild neu setzen.
Oh, Widow, Widow, Widow.
Nice res, huge res.
Wie sie sich picken lassen.
Oh, an a low bridge.
Nein.
Und auch noch ne Minute.
Hätten wir nicht noch eine Sekunde länger halten können.
Ich meine, ich hätte mein, mein mini Graviton Surge Ding aufheben sollen, da hätte ich vielleicht von der Brücke runter ziehen können oder sowas.
Wie sie sich flamen.
OVL ist Overwatch League, also die offizielle eSports, wie nennt man das so, Division, nee, keine Ahnung, halt die offizielle Liga von Blizzard für Overwatch, setz mal so, simpel zu sagen.
Was?
Oh Gott, was ist das für ein Plet Strats oder was, was gibt das jetzt?
What the fuck?
Was soll denn das geben, wenn es fertig ist, Omega Null.
Wo ist der Sniper?
Die haben doch nicht mal richtige Heal.
Der hat bestimmt Shatter.
Ah.
What, ist einer gelieft?
Okay, nee, keiner gelieft.
Was sind das für Strats?
Was ist das, was ist das?
The fuck, the fuck, was gibt das denn?
Okay, ich mach das schon, ich mach das schon, easy, easy clap, easy win, easy win.
Was ich gut find, die sind nicht hier gleich ultra toxic am Start.
Ich find's geil, der eine ist 12 und nicht im Stimmbruch, der andere ist 13 und hat gerade im Stimmbruch.
Ich muss aufpassen.
What the fuck?
Okay, das war ziemlich dumm, dass ich auf den Reihen hat.
Was, was machen die denn da?
Ich weiß es nicht, das ist mir zu hoch.
Die wollten rechts hoch, habt ihr das verstanden, dass die rechts hoch wollten?
Behind you, behind you.
Was, warum, warum chargeen wir die nicht weg?
Megascheiß Taktik, ey, was geht ab?
Was ist das, what the fuck?
Okay, mit bestchen Old geht das, geht das.
Rikt, huge bomb.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Ja, die hatten Olds und wir hatten keine.
Nein, warum hat er sein Schild nicht hoch gemacht?
Easy clap, easy.
Nice strats by the way.
Was war das denn?
Was war denn das für ein Game, ey?
Okay, was sind wir jetzt am Ende, 3308?
Im Prinzip ist unser Win-Record heute irgendwas um, keine Ahnung, 11 zu 2 oder so.
Ich hoffe, euch hat es gefallen.
Machts gut, freizeu hosten.
Spamt ihn mal bitte zu.
Freizeur raid.
Bis zum nächsten Mal, tschüss!